confirmation hearings begin monday on
capitol hill for president biden's
supreme court nominee judge katanji
brown jackson if approved she would be
the first african-american woman to
serve on the highest court in the
country it's a distinction believe it or
not that one of her friends first
predicted way back when they met in
college nancy cordes caught up with
three of judge jackson's oldest friends
i've always known she could be the one
lisa fairfax has known katanji brown
jackson for more than half her life
cheering her on as she went from public
defender to federal judge to supreme
court nominee the unmitigated joy of
seeing someone that i love be nominated
is why i'm still smiling right now and
probably getting ready
to tear up fairfax is one-fourth of a
remarkable quartet
four women who met their freshman year
at harvard university and all went on
together to harvard law school i think
it was divine intervention like fairfax
antoinette coakley is now a law
professor nina simmons is a corporate
attorney we met we bonded we became
roommates and then we became lifelong
friends
fairfax says it was a young katanji
brown the child of two teachers who
pushed her friends to excel
i remember she would say to me you know
so much can be done early in the morning
really you're like we're in college i
think i'll sleep in sleep right now
but you know that that was her always
focused and dedicated by sophomore year
coakley was openly predicting that her
roommate would someday be the first
black woman to be named to the supreme
court thank you very much mr president i
am
truly humbled that is really true
that is really true i thought if there
was ever an opportunity for someone that
came from our background to ascend to
those heights it would be her it had to
be her she had the keen intelligence the
brilliance the ability to bring people
together but believing it and seeing it
happen are two different things
president biden has narrowed his list of
potential supreme court nominees to one
i just pulled over i'm just sat in the
car
i'm like sobbing hysterically my hands
are shaking
immediately i call nina and nina picks
up and i just scream we're screaming
like
oh my god we just screamed jumping up
and down my kids were like what's wrong
what's wrong i'm like
then i guess someone texted my daughter
and she's like okay i know why you're
screaming now they call themselves her
hype team as she plows through meetings
with dozens of senators i've been
sending her scriptures and and prayers
and you know songs
that i know
will inspire her and encourage her
because this is a lot some moments are
harder than others how did you feel and
how did she feel
when you heard some people saying well
president biden established a quota yeah
and she's just going to be there to meet
a quota how i felt is that they don't
understand
they don't understand that
if there's a barrier in place
you can't ignore it what does it mean
her nomination and hopefully
confirmation what does it mean
it means america come on yes
this is who we want to be
this is who we said we want to be
and there's another first to think about
here too if confirmed judge katanji
brown jackson would be the first former
public defender to sit on the high court
meaning that for years she represented
defendants who otherwise could not have
afforded an attorney a right enshrined
in the constitution gail
you can always count on your girlfriends
to get you through and support you and
lift you up thank you nancy that was
really lovely